はい本館てルアー
[音楽]
ちょっとだけねちょっとだけ怒ってます外れ成長であの皆さんツイッターを使ってます
でしょうか
twitter っていうのはアカウントが無いの利用できないんですけどもその
アカウントでログインする必要なものが2つありまして id とパスワードさえあれ
ば入れるんですよ
で僕のツイッターたば今日本良いが合意くらいなんですけども
した皆さん
pr
施工図中です今地下大改造中なんで是非お楽しみに黒のツイッターがですね今多分日本
だいたい恋か良いが6位くらいので相当多分フォロワー性的に多い方なんですけども
肇社長っていう id でツイッターやらせていただいておりまして id ても公表
されるもんなんであの肇社長っていうアイディアも皆分かってますつまり僕の
パスワード細部わかれば
誰のログの twitter にログインできるんでそしてなんと
ログインしようとした人がいたら僕の方にメールが来るようになってるんです
そりゃそうだがみんな俺のツイッターのエフェクトメッセージっきりなるだろうな
印刷をは twitter のダイレクトメッセージでどんな女の子と連絡を取り合っ
てるのかなるよねー
連絡取り合ってない
今はですけどね実際とか dm と気になってる人が多いと思うんでログインできれば
僕のアカウントで好きな事呟きますからそういう悪い奴らがどんなにいるのかっていう
のが実はノックカウントできるんですよ誰にも言ってなかったんですけども結構な人が
ですね僕のツイッター乗っ取ろうと頑張ってるんですよ実はこれけっこう衝撃の事実だ
と思うんですけどもまずでもネットよ悪い
葛飾オーナーと言うけど今日はさかのぼってですねえと今まで果たして何人の人が僕の
ツイッターを乗っ取ろうと頑張ったのかをちょっと調べてみると思いますで会い
ましょうは許さんけどな
おっぱい的で見ていきますこちらの僕のツイッターですねご覧ください follow
宛てが42015295に420万人の方
いつもツイッターありがとうございますまだの方は是非コチラから
ローしてくださいなんで映った多いんだろうなあはいこちらですねご覧ください
僕一回もツイッターがパスワードをリセットしようとしたことないんですけども
多分悪い奴らが twitter でログインしようとするとパスワードを打ち間違え
てパスワードを間違えてますよってくるんですよねそしたらどういうのが出るかと言い
ますと明日ワードを変更しますかとかパスワードを忘れましたかっていうのが出てそれ
を押すちゃ
道
ファロスちゃうと僕のメールの方にパスワードのリセットしますかっていう連絡が来
ちゃうんで
うるさいとは言えませんお仕事なのでなのでここでパスワードにセットしますかって奴
はパスワードを変更しますかとかパスワード忘れましたってやつをおっしゃった人の数
でございます見ていきましょう
3でもめっちゃさんに8月29ですよもうちょっと何もやろう知っていますからねそれ
も2人でなり8月2日にもいます
7月31日もいます7月20日もいます
7月
その8問今さ大体何か10日に1回ぐらい人がいるぐらいです
あの子者が書いてるね3月19を染めてなく3月14どうした
やばいよ14mar 20回パスワード僕ので入ろうと思った人がいたんですよオレ
モー
悪いよたった一つ言わせて下さいあの僕のツイッターのパスワード絶対わからないけ
よねーめっちゃ難しい安売りしてるからまずで回復不可能だと思いますすみませんあの
ハッカーの人入らないでください9感じですねちょっと今年だけで何にいたらちょっと
数えてみましょうか12
3456789
2時に2324あ
今年はまあまあいませんね今日の悪いぞ24回まあ一人一回だったら24人の人が僕の
ツイッターに各に入ろうとしました
ざけんじゃ今年は24年去年がやばかって気がするんですよねちょっと去年数えてみ
ますね
ブーブーやばくね2018年
2月に何があった2月に100人以上の人がゴミのチーターにロウ検証としてんだけど
怖い怖い怖い
181180円に曲182
[音楽]
ふふん
me
あって売れああああ2
ni ne
霊脈な立つ何人もの人が俺を twitter へ入ろうとしても大丈夫ざけんじゃ
どうですか皆さんこれが twitter の民度ですや混ぜてヤバイって100人
以上の人が僕のツイッター乗っ取ろうとするわけですからネネットのマナー飲まれ
すぎる家でもすごいよねでも確か400
[音楽]
いやでもスムーズ420万人のフォロワーがあるしたのは担当でログインできたら
そりゃテンション上がりますからねまあやりたい気持ちも十分わかりますが許さねえぞ
甚平を違う
[音楽]
me
バッハ